[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
deutsch-französische solidarität mit der
ukraine emanuel makro und olaf scholz am
abend vor dem brandenburger tor
präsident und bundeskanzler haben sich
natürlich auch darüber ausgetauscht wie
putins auftritt heute in moskau zu
bewerten ist guten abend zum heute schon
ein dass eigentümlichste des heutigen
tages war vielleicht dass der kreml fast
eine art business as usual präsentation
seiner weltkriegs siegesparaden lieferte
es wurde jedenfalls kein krieg erklärt
schon gar kein dritter weltkrieg putin
nahm das wort krieg noch nicht mal in
den mund und er rief auch nicht zu einer
landesweiten mobilmachung auf was man
sich erwartet hatten genauso wenig
erklärte er irgendeinen aktuellen sieg
was faktisch auch schwerlich möglich
wäre aber fakten haben den kreml ja
selten von propaganda abgehalten andreas
weise über das was heute in moskau
bücher und was nicht geschah
es soll eine machtdemonstration seien
vom russischen staatsfernsehen
aufwendiger bildsprache präsentiert die
sieges parade auf dem roten platz
eigentlich also fast alles wie immer
aber nur fast zum einen fehlten
kampfjets die sonst zu diesem anlass
über das zentrum moskaus dollar das
wetter habe das nicht zugelassen sowie
offizielle begründung zum anderen
warteten diesmal alle mit spannung auf
die traditionell recht kurze ansprache
des präsidenten
doch weder wurden weitere
eskalationsstufen erklommen noch
friedensangebote gemacht putin geht es
vor allem um die rechtfertigung des
überfalls auf das nachbarland
wir hatten gesehen wie eine militärische
infrastruktur entstand die hunderte
ausländische berater ihre arbeit
aufnahmen regelmäßige lieferungen
modernster waffen aus den nato-ländern
erfolgten die bedrohung mit jedem tag zu
russland hat der aggression eine
präventive abfuhr erteilt
quasi gefahr im verzug auch wenn das
durch nichts belegt ist ungewöhnlich die
zusagen großzügiger hilfen für die
hinterbliebenen in der ukraine
gefallener oder verwundeter soldaten
anlässlich dieser parade
der staat die regionen wie unternehmen
und gesellschaftlichen organisationen
werden alles tun um solche familien mit
fürsorge zu umgeben um ihnen zu helfen
besondere unterstützung werden wir den
kindern der gefallenen und verwundeten
kampfgefährten gewähren ein
präsidentenerlass ist dazu heute
unterzeichnet worden
offiziell wird derzeit von russischer
seite keine zahl von gefallenen genannt
doch die sorge scheint gross je mehr
särge aus der ukraine zurück kommen
desto unruhiger könnte es im volk werden
heute aber viel unterstützung für putin
und seinem kurs nach dem militär gehören
die straßen rund um den roten platz den
bürgern aus allen landesteilen sie
machen mit beim sogenannten
unsterblichen regiment zeigen bilder
gefallener aus jedem krieg seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg auch von soldaten die
in der ukraine starben und präsident
putin mitten unter ihnen zeigte er sich
in letzter zeit doch lieber an meter
langen tischen von gesprächspartnern
getrennt so scheint er jetzt den kontakt
zum volk zu suchen und viele folgen
seiner erzählung von sogenannten nazis
in der ukraine und dass der westen
russland attackieren wollen
wenn es da keine nazi regierung mehr
gibt wird es auch frieden geben
ich denke dass das alles von amerika
ausgeht dass die unser land in ihren
besitz bringen und all unsere
bodenschätze und reichtümer haben wollen
denn das was wir besitzen lockt sie sehr
zum beispiel das erdgas
ein tag des sieges mitten im krieg und
viele fragen bleiben offen
schalten wir erstmal nach moskau zu
unserem korrespondenten christiansen was
ist denn diese parade gibt es ja nun
jedes jahr aber in was für eine
atmosphäre hast du das diesmal erlebt
ja vielleicht mir putin hat sich die
große bühne hier selbst bereitet die
innenstadt abgesperrt überall ende
fahren und dann die große parade hier
auf dem roten platz hinter mir und auch
wenn man da jetzt nicht viel neues
erfahren hat in der rede es wurde ja
vorher spekuliert was er alles sagen
könnte ist es doch erstaunlich und es
zeigt auch wie wichtig das ist was putin
heute gesagt hat wer mit einigen
menschen hier gesprochen und die
wiederholen doch gebetsmühlenartig was
putin auch eben als argumente
hervorgebracht hat warum diese spezielle
militäroperationen sein muss und das
zeigt einfach wie wichtig es ist wie
auch die propaganda hier funktionierten
sich das in den köpfen der menschen
festsetzt kritische stimmen die haben
wir hier heute gar nicht gehört die sind
ja im prinzip komplett von der straße
verbannt worten das hat putin in den
letzten monaten und wochen geschaffen
trotzdem gab es eine kleine
protestaktion heute im
satellitenfernsehen im russischen und
auch bei einem internetportal wurden
anti kriegs botschaften verbreitet also
so ganz wollen die kritischen stimmen
dann doch nicht verschwinden
danke dir für diese einschätzung nach
moskau diese eindrücke
derweil hat sich heute auch der
ukrainische präsident geäußert selensky
erinnerte an den zweiten weltkrieg und
sagte wir haben damals gewonnen wir
werden auch diesmal gewinnen und fügte
hinzu schon bald würden in der ukraine
zwei tage
residenz in enns gemacht der eigene für
eigenen bevölkerung mit katrin eigendorf
in kiew wie wurde denn der auftritt
putins in der ukraine ja wahrgenommen
eingeschätzt
hier in kiew war es eigentlich ein
gespenstisch still am abend heute es hat
wieder flug alarm gegeben
die menschen hier haben doch angst vor
weiteren angriffen auch auf die
hauptstadt kiew davor war ja immer
wieder gewarnt worden aber die rede
putins hat hier nicht wirklich für
erstaunen gesorgt die menschen mit denen
wir hier heute gesprochen haben die
haben eigentlich alle übereinstimmend
gesagt das sind die gleichen alten lügen
die wir jetzt schon seit wochen hören da
ist ja nichts neues passiert und auch
die politischen kommentatoren haben
eigentlich er diese rede als schwäche
putins inter frittiert und haben gesagt
es fehlt völlig division putin erzählt
immer wieder das gleiche narrativ von
der faschisten regierung die ihr hier
entmachten will die ganze welt weiß dass
es sich hier um eine lüge handelt und
sagen wir mal die ideologische
eskalation mit der man hier gerechnet
hat dass er sein eigenes volk noch
einmal weiter gegen die ukraine auf
bringt diesen krieg noch mal deutlich
eskaliert das ist ja ausgeblieben und
auch das haben die argumente haben die
kommentatoren als schwäche gewertet man
hat hier ganz genau hingeguckt wie wird
dieser tag in moskau inszeniert und was
zum beispiel sofort eine meldung wert
war war die tatsache dass überall im
land ja die flugschauen abgesagt wurden
angeblich wegen des wetters da waren die
kommentatoren sich sofort einig dass das
ja nur auch wieder eine weitere lüge ist
und dass auch dies wahrscheinlich ein
zeichen der schwäche ist und man fragte
sich ja hat putin vielleicht überhaupt
noch genug flugzeuge zur verfügung um
das so zu inszenieren
das ist der tag hier in der ukraine
gewesen aber natürlich überwiegt bei den
menschen hier die angst davor dies dass
dieser krieg weiter in extremer
brutalität geführt wird denn es gab hier
aus moskau überhaupt keine anzeichen
dafür dass man in irgendeiner form hier
auf die ukraine zu gehen will sondern
der krieg geht weiter dankeschön katrin
diese einschätzung zu ihren eindrücken
in kiew befragt wie sie nachher im
heute-journal update auch noch
bundestags präsidentin bärbel barsten
heute von ihrem ukraine besuch
zurückgekehrt ist
ja wie katrin eigendorf eben sagte der
krieg geht weiter
es wird weiter bombardiert und
verschleppt gekämpft und gestorben wo
russland und die ukraine militärisch
stehen an diesem tag der erinnerung an
vergangene siege dazu gleich noch ein
gespräch mit ex general ramms sofort
zeichnet yasin herlein ein bild der
aktuellen lage
auch in mario pohl der zerstörten
geschundenen stadt wurde von einigen
heute der sieg des neunten mai gefeiert
von angehörigen der russischen
minderheit in der ost ukraine
zunächst haben die behörden es nicht
erlaubt aber jede familie hat diesen
feiertag doch begangen das
bürgermeisteramt hat uns genehmigt dass
wir blumen niederlegen seit 2014 ist uns
klar dass wir wieder mit russland
vereint sein werden
auf den osten der ukraine den teil des
landes mit dem größten
russischsprachigen bevölkerungsteil
hatten sich ja zuletzt die militärischen
aktionen der russischen armee
konzentriert doch seit tagen ist der
frontverlauf weiter weitgehend
unverändert schwere kämpfe gibt es nach
wie vor um mario pohl und das dortige
stahlwerk diese bilder zeigen schwere
einschläge die gestern von dort
evakuierten zivilisten kamen heute in
einem nachbarort an
das größte problem war an brennholz und
an essen heranzukommen um die menschen
satt zu kriegen ohne verletzt zu werden
denn ich musste dies tun während wir
bombardiert wurden
gekämpft wird auch im dom bassum städte
wie kratos sind die zerstörungen massiv
um ein geschlossenes band im osten und
süden und den zugang zum schwarzen meer
zu kontrollieren müsste die russische
armee odessa einnehmen heute wurde die
millionenstadt von raketen getroffen
eu-ratspräsident michelle der sich zu
gesprächen dort aufhielt musste in
sicherheit gebracht werden
mein rat ist so geschaltet general idea
des jahres der bundeswehr und er war
einer der höchsten nato generäle
genommen ramms
gut vorstellen können sie haben sich die
rede von putin und den ganzen auftritt
dieser parade heute natürlich auch
angesehen was haben sie davon für einen
eindruck mitgenommen
das war eine veranstaltung heute bin ich
die mit früheren siegesparaden zum
neunten mal vergleichen dann würde ich
sagen sie hat mit gebremstem schaum
stattgefunden und bei der rede von putin
fand ich interessant dass er versucht
hat die brücke zu knüpfen von den
veteranen die den sieg über nazi
deutschland errungen haben zu den
kämpfern die heute im donbass
beziehungsweise in der ukraine kämpfen
er hat damit eine versuchte eine
gemeinsamkeit zu beschwören und
möglicherweise die soldaten dem don was
eingesetzt sind auf diese art und weise
auch entsprechend zu motivieren
und deshalb bei solchen paraden ist aus
sicht eines militärs ja auch was da so
wie die straße rollt oder was davor
geführt wird und sagen manche wir haben
da in den letzten jahren so manches
vorgeführt bekommen was bombastisch
aussah aber was auf den schlachtfeldern
gar nicht zu sehen ist bestimmte panzer
typen zum beispiel werden da zum teil
auch potemkin schritt dafür präsentiert
also mit dem begriff britisches dorf
wäre ich vorsichtig aber sie haben recht
mit der feststellung dass beispielsweise
der modernsten kampfpanzer russlands der
tvh marta ist er auf den schlachtfeldern
ukraine nicht aufgetaucht ist was ein
vorteil sicherlich auch für die ukraine
ist keine frage wovon aber
möglicherweise auch bisher nur so
geringe stückzahlen produziert worden
sind dass es keinen sinn macht diese
branche einzusetzen sie befinden sich im
westlichen militärbezirks sie gehören
beispielsweise zur ersten garde
panzerarmee dann reden wir über sankt
petersburg und ich glaube nicht dass
putin diese westflanke für ihn und
nordwest flanke für ihn von militärs von
schwerem gerät befreien wird weil er ja
der phobie lebt in der nato phobie lebt
dass die leute ihn angreifen könnte was
wir aufgrund der geschichte der nato
eindeutig widerlegt was heute auch
diskutiert wurde wären es eben gehört
dass in der ukraine auch für besondere
aufmerksamkeit sorgte dass diese
flugzeuge obwohl diese eifrig geübt
hatten und wohl auch ein großes zetteln
himmel schreiben sollten also dass diese
kampfflieger heute über moskau nicht
gestartet sind gibt es aus militärischer
sicht eine eine plausible erklärung oder
kann man nur spekulieren
also man kann eigentlich nur spekulieren
darüber
dass java verschiedene sieges beraten
diese flugeinlagen geben sollte nicht
nur in moskau und wenn dann die gesamte
luftwaffe nicht in die luft kommt dann
ist irgendwas nicht in ordnung das kann
auch dann aufgrund der unterschiedlichen
wetterlagen in verschiedenen bereichen
nicht nur wetter gelegen haben wir
können elektronische sachen gründe eine
rolle spielen da können
einsatzbereitschaft eine rolle spielen
auf jeden fall ist dieses ein punkt den
man noch mal sorgfältig auswerten sollte
und ich bin davon überzeugt dass die
geheimdienste dem regal und der briten
dieses in den nächsten tagen machen
würden man fragt sich ja sowieso wie es
um die zugkraft der russen stellt es ist
erstaunlich dass die ukraine immer noch
fliegen und das die russen bislang bei
weitem nicht die wirkliche lufthoheit
erreicht haben wenn man das leiden hat
sagen dafür über der ukraine oder wie
sehen sie das
also die russen sind in bestimmten
bereichen mit ihren luftstreitkräften
den ukrainer ein deutlich überlegen aber
wenn wir beispielsweise runtergehen nach
süden also weiter weg von der russisch
ukrainischen grenze dann verändert sich
dieses verhältnis eindeutig wandert die
sagt man luftwaffen einsätze der ukraine
im bereich der schlangen insel gesehen
das war schon zum teil beeindruckend und
wenn die ukraine dort noch und dieser
form fliegen können dann zeigt das auch
dass sie offensichtlich ihre technik im
griff haben und dass sie auch in der
lage sind trotz angriffe nur flughäfen
und angriffe nur flugzeuge die auf buch
hilfen stehen immer noch teufel in die
luft zu bringen es wäre wahrscheinlich
trotzdem ein fehler die die russische
feuerkraft um die tatkraft zu
unterschätzen und sich in der hoffnung
zu wählen dass es da steht über kurz
oder lang ein sieg der ukraine vor der
tür oder wie schätzen sie das ein
also über kurz oder lang das schon eher
lang das wird noch eine erhebliche zeit
in anspruch nehmen in dieser beziehung
ist die ukrainische auch abhängig von
den waffenlieferungen aus dem westen
weil sie selber nicht genügend schweres
gerät hat und entspricht nicht sagt
angriffs weise gegen die russen in den
bereichen die russen besetzt haben
vorzugehen das macht die sache dann
schon relativ schwierig und das spricht
eher dafür dass diese auseinandersetzung
noch ein erheblich lange zeit dauern
wird eine weitere anmerkung zu dem thema
ist das offensichtlich ich sag das mal
von nachrichtendiensten im westen aber
auch von uns insgesamt die schlagkraft
der russischen streitkräfte deutlich
überschätzt worden ist
das zeigte sich auch in den kämpfen und
ihr von den handlungen die dann
hinterher gefolgt sind
das allein die kaufbeurer der
ukrainische streit dürfte in der lage
war die angeblich überlegt großtechnik
aufzuhalten
drum ist dank ins gespräch
herzlichen dank gerne
prozent steht einerseits da wenn zwar
nicht wie ein kaiser ohne kleider aber
so doch einer mit irgendwie beschränkter
garderobe andererseits gab er wilde
verschwörungstheorien von sich und
zeichnete dieses verhältnis zwischen
nato und kleine und ihnen eigentlich in
einer form klassischer täter opfer
umkehr wie man im politischen berlin und
anderen hauptstädten auf die routine
rede heute reagiert wurde das fast jetzt
andreas cüppers zusammen
sie nehmen den ordner und dann können
sie hier ganz normal ihren perioden das
branche das ist ein kampf um symbole an
diesem 9 mai in berlin und er wird
unerbittlich geführt um das st georgs
band zum beispiel jenes russische
militär abzeichen das heute verboten ist
am sowjetischen ehrenmal in
berlin-treptow aber nicht jedem verboten
werden kann man hat russlands
botschafter in deutschland seit wochen
nicht gesehen und so noch nie es ist ein
kampf um symbole an diesem 9 mai an dem
die erste auslandsreise frankreichs
wiedergewählten präsidenten auf die
terrasse des bundeskanzleramtes führt
makro und scholz geben die antwort auf
die rede des russischen präsidenten in
berlin und gemeinsam
die macht ich denke dass es heute keine
weitere eskalation graf keine verbale
eskalation keine geografische eskalation
aber auch keine eskalation durch die
verwendung von waffen ist das
ausreichend oder zufriedenstellend nein
denn was wir erreichen wollen ist eine
waffenruhe
was russland erreichen will stellt
seinen botschafter klar 77 jahre nach
dem ende des nationalsozialismus soll
mit der ukraine das nächste land
entnazifiziert werden
propaganda am anti kriegs denkmal
ratifiziert wird es ganz wichtig
meinen sie das wird nicht gelingt und
das gelingt
[Musik]
einen frieden und
die ukraine als nazi land wie einst
nazi-deutschland für viele unerträglich
ich möchte ich das gar nicht
kommentieren weil das so falsch ist wir
haben wirklich allen gedacht und wenn
ich sehe dass menschen
holocaust-überlebende durch angriffe der
russen gestorben sind halte ich das für
ein wirklich perfektes beispiel einer
bestimmten propaganda die durchgesetzt
werden soll es ist ein kampf um symbole
an diesem 9 er wird stumm und hilflos
geführt in berlin und laut und voller
wut in warschau russlands botschafter in
polen mit roter farbe attackiert als
mörder mörder beschimpft und an der
kranzniederlegung gehindert
makro und scholz versuchen in berlin den
eindruck zu zerstreuen das deutschland
der ukraine weniger entschlossen hilft
als andere staaten wenn sie sich genau
anschauen und das werden sie versichert
und werden sie sehen dass die politik
von deutschland frankreich italien
spanien großbritannien und den usa hat
sich nicht unterscheiden sondern dass
sie komplett identisch sind in der frage
was wir machen und auf welche weise wird
diese hilfe zur verfügung stellen es ist
ein kampf der symbole am tag der
militärparade in moskau ein
abendspaziergang in berlin putin auf dem
roten platz kanzler und präsident auf
dem blau-gelben
zu den mutmasslich ungewollten
nebenwirkungen der putin schon invasion
gehört dass sich schweden und finnland
aller voraussicht nach auf den weg in
die nato machen und die ukraine noch
drängender an die tür der eu klopft als
zuvor mit dem thema beginnt die
nachrichten dann heißt es geht zunächst
um die frage ob die ukraine wie
gewünscht offiziell eu beitrittskandidat
werden kann dazu will die eu-kommission
laut präsidentin von der leyen
voraussichtlich noch im juni eine
stellungnahme abgeben
frankreichs präsident marc reinhardt
hoffnungen auf einen schnellen
eu-beitritt gedämpft das verfahren könne
jahrzehnte dauern er schlug stattdessen
eine europäische politische gemeinschaft
mit neuen formen der zusammenarbeit vor
die bundesregierung zeigt sich
zuversichtlich die raffinerie im
brandenburgischen schwedt mit rund 1200
beschäftigten erhalten zu können trotz
des geplanten öl-embargo der eu gegen
russland bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck sagte heute bei einem besuch der
raffinerie die vorbereitungen für neue
ölquellen über schiffe via rostock sowie
die finanzierung von verlusten und eine
mögliche treuhand struktur liefen
bereits wenn alles drei klappe hätten
die beschäftigten jobsicherheit für die
nächste zeit
die bundesregierung hat eine serie von
cyber angriffen auf deutsche behörden
und ministerien in den vergangenen tagen
bestätigt die angriffe seien simpel
strukturiert gewesen und hätten
abgewehrt werden können daten wurden
demnach nicht gestohlen eine russische
hacker gruppe bekannte sich zu den
attacken
nach der landtagswahl in schleswig
holstein hat sich ministerpräsident
günther auch heute bedeckt gehalten mit
wem er die nächste regierung bilden er
sagte habe sowohl die grünen als auch
die fdp zu gesprächen eingeladen und
kündigte sondierungsgespräche für
dienstag nächster woche an laut
vorläufigem amtlichen endergebnis liegt
die cdu deutlich zu und kommt auf 43,4
prozent die grünen werden zweitstärkste
kraft erreichen 18,3 prozent die spd
schafft nur noch 16 die fdp 6,4 prozent
der südschleswigsche wählerverband legt
zu und kommt auf
5,7 prozent die afg es mit 44 prozent
nicht dem landtag
bei der präsidentenwahl auf den
philippinen liegt nach ersten berichten
der sohn des ehemaligen diktators
ferdinand marcos klar vorne demnach
könnte fast 40 jahre nach absetzung
seines vaters nun ferdinand marcos
junior staatsoberhaupt werden der
bisherige präsident du tertre durfte
nicht für eine weitere amtszeit antreten
in sri lanka ist nach landesweiten
demonstrationen minister präsident
rajapakse zurückgetreten er wolle damit
so hieß es den weg für eine
alleinregierung freimachen vor der
rücktrittsankündigung hatte es
gewaltsame zusammenstöße zwischen
regierungsgegnern und befürwortern
gegeben laut polizei wurden mindestens
130 menschen verletzt sri lanka steckt
in einer wirtschaftskrise es fehlt an
treibstoff lebensmitteln und
medikamenten
noch leben wir in einem zeitalter in dem
es immer wieder heißt dass diese oder
jene position erstmals an eine frau geht
naja so wird immerhin jedes mal bewusst
dass das ein erstmals ist etwa beim
deutschen gewerkschaftsbund
an der spitze des dachverbands in dem
rund 5,7 millionen mitglieder
organisiert sind steht von heute an die
spd-politikerin jasmine v über ihre wahl
berichten andrea support und nass
wohl wahr frauen die gibt es hier und
seit heute auch an der spitze des dgb
jasmin familie ist die neue vorsitzende
nach über 70 jahren wird erstmals eine
frau oberste gewerkschafterin in
deutschland die gleichberechtigung hat
sie sich auf die fahnen geschrieben
deswegen weg mit der sachgrundlosen
befristung den mini jobs in teilzeit
fallen weg mit dem paragraphen 219 a und
keine milde bei gewalt gegen frauen in
diesem land wir wollen brot und rosen
kolleginnen die passende dna die hat die
kollegin verliebt sie kommt von der ig
bergbau chemie und energie wechselt dann
in die politik wird spd
generalsekretärin
bundestagsabgeordnete und
staatssekretärin im arbeitsministerium
jetzt der weg zurück in den schoß der
gewerkschaften nicht alle mitglieder
waren damit einverstanden auch wenn das
jetzt keiner mehr zu geben will die
hälfte aller beschäftigten sind weiblich
und deswegen tut es gut wenn an der
spitze des deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes
eine frau steht für chemie übernimmt den
dgb in schwierigen zeiten nach zwei
jahren pandemie gefährdet die jetzt der
ukraine krieg wohlstand und
arbeitsplätze in deutschland
wenn morgen die chemische industrie
stillsteht gibt es weder für die
pharmazeutische industrie noch für die
landwirtschaft ammoniak es gibt keine
hightech kunststoffe und lacke für
windkrafträder keine batterien für
elektroautos und keine dämmstoffe für
die energetische gebäudesanierung
die gewerkschaften verstehen sich
traditionell als teil der
friedensbewegung trotzdem sagen sie ja
zu waffenlieferungen und befürworten
auch die 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
allerdings was nicht sein kann ist das
ist so frei bleibt und auf der anderen
seite eben investitionsmittel nachher
fehlen den sozialen zusammenhalt und da
ist das etwas was wir unbedingt
garantieren müssen eine klare ansage an
die ampel koalition und an den spd
kanzler der verspricht vor dem dgb
kongress trotz hoher rüstungsausgaben
werde es keine sozialkürzungen geben wir
werden die projekte die wir für den
transformationen für die neue ausrüstung
unserer wirtschaft aber auch für den
sozialen zusammenhalt in deutschland uns
fest vorgenommen haben nicht einstellen
sie werden jetzt erst nötig seien erst
recht nötig ist für die gewerkschaften
übrigens ein kräftiger schluck aus der
lohnpulle die inflation die hohen
energie und lebensmittelpreise muss
durch steigende gehälter ausgeglichen
werde die preise steigen enorm und
gerade für menschen mit normalen und
eher geringen einkommen ist das extrem
belastend und von daher ist unser
anspruch und unser ziel in allen
tarifrunden die jetzt stattfinden und in
der nächsten zeit stattfinden diese
preissteigerungsrate auszugleichen krieg
klimakrise inflation umbau der
arbeitswelt ordentlich dicke bretter die
zu bohren sind für die erste frau an der
spitze des dgb und
[Applaus]
jetzt nochmal heinz auch mit wirtschaft
für unternehmen die von folgen des
ukraine krieges betroffen sind hat die
bundesregierung ein hilfspaket
vorgesehen dazu gehört auch ein
sonderkreditprogramm das heute anlaufen
soll weil er ja für wen gibt es da
welche unterstützung ja um 1 mal vorweg
zu schicken viele deutsche unternehmen
spüren ja den krieg in der ukraine in
einer situation in der viele wegen der
korona pandemie schon keine dicken
finanzpolster mehr haben und die kfw
will nun mit günstigen krediten helfen
unternehmen aller größen und branchen
entscheidend ist dass sie nachweisen
können wie sie konkret wirtschaftlich
von den sanktionen gegen russland oder
dem krieg in der ukraine betroffen sind
einen kredit kann and erhalten dem
beispielsweise absatzmärkte weggebrochen
sind schaden entstanden ist durch
geschlossene fabriken vor ort oder beim
rohstoffe oder vorprodukte fehlen und
schließlich falls besonders hohe
energiekosten das geschäft stark
belasten vorgesehen sind in der regel
summen von bis zu 100 millionen euro das
geld bekommen sie über ihre hausbank das
ausfallrisiko liegt überwiegend beim
start dafür sind bis jahresende 7
milliarden euro im topf damit verbunden
die hoffnung die folgen des krieges für
die deutsche wirtschaft wenigstens etwas
abzufedern doch anders als die üppigen
corona helfen fällt dieses paket dann
doch deutlich kleiner aus und ist er als
stoßdämpfer gedacht sorgen um die
konjunktur treiben auch aktienanleger um
der dax heute deutlich im minus was vor
allem daran liegt dass chinas konjunktur
schwächelt sind keine guten vorzeichen
für die deutsche wirtschaft deren
wichtigster handelspartner nunmal china
ist valerie haller vielen dank
in der formel 1 hat max verstappen im
großen preis von miami gewonnen vor
schale claire und carlos sainz
verstauten verkürzte mit diesem sieg bei
der premiere in miami den rückstand auf
den in der gesamtwertung für unter den
schaden erklärt um 2 auf 19 punkte pech
hatte mit schumacher der kurz vor
schluss auf platz neun liegend mit
sebastian vettel kollidierte und erneut
ohne punkte blieb
das was uns gleich nach dem wetter geht
es im zdf montagskino weiter oder um 0
uhr gibt es dann unser heute schnell ab
stellt mit wulf schmiese bis morgen habe
der serie wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend für ein kurzes
frühsommerliches internet so reicht es
dass dieses hoch wolf über uns
hinweggezogen ist und nun weiter
richtung süden zieht es wird erstmal
deutlich milder wir erwarten bis zu 30
grad am mittwoch auch wenn die wärme
nicht alle trifft sie sehen hier ziehen
auch einige regenwolken morgen über den
norden deutschlands
es wird also erstmal sehr mild und das
merken wir auch nachts da sinken die
temperaturen in der west hälfte nämlich
nicht unter 14 bis 10 grad das ist schon
sehr mild zum teil hatten wir ja diese
nacht im norden noch frost kühler wird
dagegen im osten und im süden bei 9 bis
4 grad die letzten regenschauer und
gewitter fallen jetzt gerade in sich
zusammen und dann bildet sich hier auch
mal etwas nebel häufig ist die nacht
aber klar und von nordwesten kommen
dichtere wolken heran diese dichteren
wolken bringen danach etwas regen mit
schon tagsüber in schleswig holstein die
meisten von uns können sich aber auf
einen sehr freundlichen dienstag
einstellen mit sonne und wolken im
wechsel bei südwesten das ist keine gute
nachricht für den nordosten deutschlands
denn da herrscht zurzeit eine extreme
waldbrandgefahr stufe 55 erreicht ihr im
südlichen brandenburg und auch an der
elbe die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen an den küsten verdaut und ostsee
bei 20 bis 22 grad 22 bis 23 grad sind
es auch vom thüringer wald bis zum
alpenrand sonst gibt es frühsommerliche
24 bis 28 grad und dann wird es von tag
zu tag kühler am samstag sind es noch 15
bis 24 grad aber erst mal wird der
heißeste tag der mittwoch seien mit bis
zu 30 grad zum beispiel am neckar guten
abend